hey youtubers is charlie so during my
arrows seeing red video i actually just
submit all your questions about the big
WTF reveals and the rest of the season
so i picked 10 of them to answer in this
video with one bonus question also if
you're finding me for the first time
just because this season 2 arrow has
been so amazing i'm doing a special
bonus countdown series to the finale so
each wednesday i'm just posting a new
bonus video be sure to subscribe to get
everything and feel free to leave me
suggestions for what you want those
videos to be about so let's talk some
connor hawke and Deathstroke careful for
spoilers for everything through episode
20 if you're not caught up yet but here
we go question number one Rose Lily asks
will Oliver tell phia that he is the
green arrow now I think that that person
that he tells in the trailer for the
next episode we saw actually is Thea but
they could be doing something a little
bit different it could just be a
misdirect because Thea is talking about
being sick of all the lies and we know
that Merlin is coming back soon so she
could just be talking to him and Oliver
could be talking to someone else but i
think the Thea will know the truth by
the finale I mean pretty much everyone
in Oliver's family figured out his
secret identity in almost all the main
characters no with the exception of
Quentin so he's either telling when or
he's telling Thea question number two
Tim asks do you think that Roy will be
fixed or healed before the season finale
yeah I think pretty much all the
mirakuru drama is going to be done
before the finale or at least you know
in the first couple moments of the
finale in the episode description for
Streets of Fire episode 22 it mentions
caitlin snow making a big breakthrough
with STAR Labs so they probably get the
Cure in that episode and use it but that
won't be the end of it obviously I think
in the finale episode 23 Slade's army
will be gone it'll just be team arrow vs
team Deathstroke just the core main
characters I think the big theme this
season or at least the second half of
the season has been full circle so think
back to when oliver and Slade's started
they were on the island by themselves
you know gradually new characters came
in it eventually got all the new team
arrow people Slade got his team and then
the army and a bunch of them obviously
you're gonna either go away or die like
they already have so these last couple
of episodes were traveling back to the
beginning so the last couple of moments
of the finale I expect it to be just
Oliver and Slade you know just like in
the beginning so I'm also saying that
yes I
them to go back to the island in the
finale question number three the PTM d3
asks who is connor hawke good question
so in case you don't know I'm just gonna
actually go based on the new 52 universe
Connor Hawke is the son of oliver queen
and sandra hog in the new 52 comics he's
also the red arrow but everyone is kind
of expecting this new kid of Oliver's to
turn out to be Connor they could be
doing something different on the show
and gender bend it and it could be his
daughter but i think i should also
mention that it would be wasting too
much of an opportunity for them to just
make the child a normal non comic book
character but even if it does turn out
to be Connor I'm not expecting Oliver to
just you know start training him right
away remember the kids only going to be
like six or seven years old so basically
this child you know we're hoping is the
implied heir of the green arrow legacy
you know someday when Oliver dies or
retires this child will take up the
mantle just like some of the Robins in
the Batman comics I've taken up the
mantle of the bat for temporary periods
of time question number four Manuel
Cortez asks is Oliver Sun the next
person who has to die according to slate
or Willy live in Oliver train him
otherwise why bring the issue to the
show so there's actually a couple
reasons why they could be dumping this
info on us right now first off I
definitely think the child will figure
into the finale you know otherwise they
would have waited to introduce him in
that season three cliffhanger you know
the moment at the very end of the finale
that doesn't mean that sleigh will try
to kill him but he's definitely done his
homework with Oliver so I think he knows
about the child and we'll just you know
hang him so to speak over Oliver's head
that could either be like Slade doing
the same you know pick who dies moment
using Felicity and Oliver son or he
could just straight-up kidnap him and
take him to the island to raise him as
his own so a couple of things have to
happen in the finale one we have to go
back to the island somehow and to
someone is definitely gonna get
kidnapped question number five Monica
pain asks what was Moira going to tell
them about Malcolm before Slade attacked
them she was just gonna tell them that
he's still alive Merlin really just said
that he wanted Thea you know he wanted
his daughter to be with him so I think
he's going to offer to take her away if
he does have some other secret plan
involving Thea the show hasn't revealed
it yet he's not coming back till episode
22 so whatever happens between daddy and
daughter will go down in that episode
the question number six laxus dreyar
asks do you think that Oliver or Thea
will take up Moira's run for mayor so
they could totally do that you know
Oliver Queen mayor of Starling city
story from the comic books it would be
an interesting wrinkle and you know
whatever the big main story of season
three is mayor and daddy by day
vigilante by night I'd rather see Diggle
or someone else be mayor but I wouldn't
be surprised if Oliver takes the job I
don't think that anybody expects brother
blood to survive as the mayor into
season three I think Laurel is
definitely gonna kill him in the finale
question number 7 Sergio asks whose
words are keeping their secret identity
a secret Oliver Queen or Bruce Wayne so
I would definitely say Oliver I think
pretty much his entire family and almost
all the main characters have figured it
out except for Thea Barry knows everyone
at Argus knows and even some of his
biggest enemies like Merlyn and Slade
know brother blood does not know which I
actually think is pretty funny it just
tells you how important that character
is to Slade Batman's secret identity has
been figured out by various you know
comic book characters and you know
special villains in the past but
generally that's been pretty rare
question number 8 Bobby asks what is
your thought about them creating a new
shared DC Universe with the movies and
TV shows and what do you think they
should include in that so David s Goyer
said something really interesting he's
mostly known for writing a lot of DC
comic books but he's the one who's
writing that Superman vs Batman movie
right now he said that warner brothers
who owns all the movie rights and most
of the TV shows and DC Comics just isn't
quite ready for a unified system like
Marvel you know not enough of the right
people in charge people at the top or on
board with the idea the problem is is
that you have this army of producers
making movies and TV shows and writing
comic books and they all have to be on
the same page it has to be like a thing
from the top down so like the CEO has to
make it his mission and then his
underlings and his underlings all the
way down to the people that are actually
writing the scripts whenever they do get
it figured out I think it should be just
like Marvel's version you know all the
studio movies and Netflix shows and TV
shows on broadcast TV should exist in
the same universe I think there are a
couple things they should leave out
though like the comic book should just
be their own thing on the side and all
the animated shows like on Nickelodeon
and Cartoon Network those should be
different too question number 9 Brad
gilbert asks does killing Moira give
merlin and team arrow a reason to unite
you know definitely but i think the real
thing that's gonna convince merlin to
fight with oliver is gonna be theah you
know Thea saying you know as my father
if you want to have a relationship with
me please help my friends and my family
defeat this you know big threat of Slade
so for Merlin I think you know because
of phia he's just gonna have a temporary
truce with team arrow you know he
doesn't hate Oliver but as Stephen Amell
once said they have unfinished business
mostly just unresolved issues from
season one like Tommy dying and the
undertaking question number 10 danske
games asks do you think the last person
that Slade said has to die is actually
himself so that should see a really
important thing to consider I don't know
the whole plot of the finale or anything
but I think it would be a really awesome
twist you know if Slade during the
process of the finale starts to realize
what he's done and is just so overcome
with grief that he asks Oliver to kill
him and just end it all if you remember
in episode 20 Roy asked Sarah to kill
him just because he didn't want to go on
living anymore so the ends up happening
with Slade's character killing him would
be like the act of mercy so I don't
think Oliver would do it you know he
still hates Slade for what he's done and
I think he's gonna force him to live
with that and one last bonus question
red arrow asks do you think that
Oliver's child in the mother will be
featured on the flash show this fall but
yes only in episodes that invoke people
from arrow I don't expect them to be
cast as regulars on the flash show I
think we're only going to see them
whenever Oliver visits the flash or
whenever the flash crosses over with
arrow that doesn't include you know
moments when they reference those
characters and we just don't see them
like for instance they've been talking
about Barry a lot since episode 9 but we
haven't seen him yet so thank you so
much for submitting questions for this
QA these are always a lot of fun to do
so my next bonus video is going to post
Wednesday before episode 21 airs be sure
to subscribe to get it and feel free to
leave me suggestions for my next couple
of bonus videos remember I'm doing one
for each of the final episodes of arrow
this season right now you can click here
for my top 10 team arrow moments this
season so far and you
click here for my review of episode 20
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow high fives
you